[Musique]
voici marie dominguez parle-moi un peu
tenable il épate je me lève jamais avant
10 heures et non à pleaux espagnol aussi
norauto bingen désolé je croyais que
vous étiez m'a dit que je ressemble à
votre soeur ah non vous n'êtes plus
grand et ponctuelles en français tout
avoir narrativement nouveau 4 4 les
flamboiements le lien c'est qu'une
voiture par auront jusqu'au jour l opow
perdu qui sait votre père a eu une
aventure avant que vous venez au monde
c'est votre frère quoi on a frère
votre père était au bord de la faillite
pour la maison nous pouvons l'acheter
donc tu es pauvre ont terminé le
shopping
les pauvres ne mange que des glucides en
part alors où est ce qu'on va à l'est de
los angeles
bienvenue au quartier ma belle tu
occupes a pas de coups alors qu'est-ce
que tu en tires ya à peine quinze
minutes et on se retrouve de l'autre
côté de la frontière
tu te connaître maria ses marines et je
ne donne pas de pourboire
on doit tirer d'ici pour aller où aux
quatre saisons
[Musique]
tu as l'air plutôt de t'être bien adapté
mon instinct de survie d'accord wen
épique rien tu crois que tous les
mexicains pigiste à rien je suis pas
mexicaine parce qu'avec un point de
jouer des sandales tu ferais un tabac en
vendant des tamales est ce vraiment très
de retard
dano venez découvrir comment on peut
trouver une famille la première qualité
de ton père il était toujours très fier
de sa famille dans un quartier une
petite fête chez ma tante si tu te sens
bénie où vous n'auriez jamais on va dire
ouais pour un employé du prix d'achat
gentil wii sort la moustache
[Musique]
et là pouf jeter à l'oeil la ligue
mexicaine
[Musique]
rodrigo antonio fuentes hidalgo des
labours bola junior aurélien margarita
jiménez six manches pour venir
faut que je me mettre sérieusement à
l'espagnol